When I got my acceptance to MIT, it was on Pi Day, which is March 14, and the admissions come out at 1:59, because pi is 3.14159.
I logged on to the webpage...
And I'm locked in my room. I'm a nervous wreck.
And I started reading the line and I started screaming.
All I saw was "It is our pleasure," and I just lost it. I jumped up...
My brother was like, "Is that good or is that bad?"
They didn't know if it was a good sign or a bad sign.
So they started screaming and jumping up and down.
And when I ran out, I kept saying, "I'm going to MIT," and then they began screaming and my mom cried.
There was a lot of screaming, a lot of screaming when I got accepted to MIT.
It was good. It was the best day of my life.
When I received my acceptance letter from MIT, I was a bit shocked at first.
I couldn't believe it. It was amazing.
I didn't really expect to get in, to be honest.
Because I didn't think I could get in.
The biggest fear that I had about MIT was that I wasn't going to be smart enough, or like the other freshmen.
I felt that they would be smarter than me.
And after attending CPW, I definitely found people that were just like me.
I came here during Campus Preview Weekend.
I came up here for CPW and I had a great time.
I got to see a lot of the student life here, and a lot of the different activities that I could choose to be a part of.
So, during my CPW experience, it was my first impression of MIT,
and I learned that everyone here is very relaxed, laid back, they're very comfortable with each other,
and there's a lot of friendship here.
I think one of the surprises that I found was just how cool everyone here is
and how much fun they are.
I chose MIT because...mostly because of the people here.
Just fantastic people, from all different backgrounds, and they just really expand your world.
I chose MIT because when I came to CPW, I met people who were fun.
During CPW, I really had the time of my life. There's so much going on.
That's what I'm looking forward to. That's what I chose MIT for.
And that's, you know, the reason I decided to come here.
That sold it for me.
I realized this was the only place I wanted to go.